foreign
Jessica's with us in Austin Texas hi
Jessica welcome to the Ramsey Show
be here good to have you how can we help
okay I have a question
um we got into some credit card trouble
um we are now being offered to settle
for uh eight thousand dollars less or we
could pay it off
um with a 500 discount at twenty
thousand but both of those are going to
hurt our credit and we're going to want
to be able to buy a house pretty soon
and I know interest rates are going to
matter should we try to settle or should
we just go ahead and pay it off even
though they're both going to leave bad
marks
so you're behind on the credit card
yeah it's it's a it's actually
it's actually um we're supposed to get a
zero percent interest rate and they
didn't do it and then they were going to
back date the interest but they've
already reported you as not paying the
credit card on time many many months
yeah so your credit has already gone
girl
yeah that's when you call me acting like
your Sterling credit and you're about to
mess it up you're already screwed
it's bad but I don't want to make it
worse I'm trying to rebuild it yeah I
don't want you to rebuild it I want you
to quit borrowing money
but what about like a house you buy a
house the way George did no credit score
and you know that means it's going to
take longer because you have to get out
of debt completely no open trade Lines
no open credit lines and then six months
later 12 months later while you're
saving up your down payment that credit
score will eventually become
indeterminable and then you can use a
process called manual underwriting to
get that house the right way down the
line so you're not ready to buy a house
anyways so I wouldn't be worried about
that yeah you're twenty thousand dollars
in debt not paying your bills on time
you don't need to talk about buying a
house right now no we have a lot of
money though we just sold a house we
have 130 000 in the bank so we're about
to be able to pay off all of our debt we
have 30 000. so total debt is 30. you
have a hundred thirty
and so what's your question today should
you do the settlement should she take a
discount on a credit card when she has
the money to pay it off you should pay
the entire bill that you owe that's
called integrity
well I understand that too but there are
also they charge an extra three thousand
dollars on top of what they were
supposed to do and I called them and I
told him I said listen I said I don't
want to I don't want to
get it for Less I want to pay what we
owe but I also want y'all to take the
interest off like y'all said that y'all
are going to do this place which is I
have a recording that they said that
they were going to do so I'm sitting
here I'm saying I don't want to take a
okay so what is the interest dispute
about explain that it was supposed to do
a zero percent interest rate on a charge
before I did the charge and I never did
it and I would call and call and call
and call and tell them that you know
it's how to fix and each time they're
like okay well we'll fix it and then
we're gonna send it up to corporate and
then we're gonna send it back up to
corporate and they're going to have to
do they're gonna have to back back track
it yeah which credit card Discover
discover yeah you discovered they suck
yeah it's incredibly and so we've been
struggling with them and fighting with
them on it and this is the first time
we've ever been an intern in trouble as
far as not paying and all your other
bills yes all my other people have
always been current so you have ten
thousand dollars in debt that is not
this what is that
um we have a Capital One credit card
it's everything else is current okay so
just pay it
and um I mean whatever you can come to
that is ethical and moral that you
really owe and you can come to that
amount pay it
and uh your credit though is already
dinged this one little thing discounting
this is not going to ding your credit
and keep you from getting a house
okay
what's your credit score now
it's like 660 it's not great well you're
not
you're not you got you got other issues
then
how do you have a 660 if you've never
been laid on anything but this one card
because it's this card that has been
digging the crap out of it no
no do you want to see it I can email you
stuff our credit report the only thing
you've ever been laid on in your life is
that one card and you have a 660.
not my entire life but it was a seven it
was like a 750 before this credit card
hit
so I mean how long have you been arguing
how long have you been late with this
card
six months we've been arguing back and
forth for the last six months wow why
even argue when you guys have the money
to pay for it they didn't at the time we
didn't we just now have the money
because you sold the house because we
sold the house and we couldn't pay it
because we couldn't get it current
because the interest rate was so high
and the minimum view was so high so we
couldn't get current but where are you
living now a rental
no um well we sold our house and my
family has a house that we're living in
it's just one of their properties that
they had how long how long can you live
there
um
I mean I don't want to stay here for too
long but for at least another year we
could live here okay what I would do is
pay off everything get the disputed
amount or not figure it out and get it
in writing that the that this takes your
balance with discover because they will
screw you as you have found out they're
a horrible company and so you need to
pay it off as soon as possible
completely and get it zeroed out and
then you have no payments of any kind
showing on your credit bureau report and
six to 12 months later your 660 will be
zero
and then you do manual underwriting the
way George said that's your shortest
that's your best shortcut because at 660
you're not getting a mortgage like you
want you're going to get a subprime
and so your best angle is to drop to
zero rather than try to get your get
your number up the only way you're going
to get this number up is keep borrowing
more money and paying it back
and go back in credit card debt and run
up a bunch of crap just to play the FICO
game and I don't play the FICO game
that's what you talk about getting
screwed those are the people screwing
you so yeah what I would do is get a
number that is ethical and proper in
writing from discover this week write
the check write the check on the other
one close both accounts and make sure
there is nothing on your credit bureau
report that is open
that every single item is closed no
trade accounts no nothing nothing is
being reported as you paying payments
and your 660 will disappear in six to 12
months and then you'll be ready and just
stay in the family house until it
disappears that's what I would do that's
the simplest path and it's the short
it's actually the shortest path yeah and
as we've seen here you play with snakes
you get bit I mean trying to get the
credit card companies to play nice and
do what they said they were going to do
is a fruitless Endeavor and it's never
worth it and people always open it going
well it's a zero percent interest I'm
getting the rewards I'm getting the
points I'm getting the sky miles and it
always ends up calling this show going
Dave or twenty thousand dollars in
credit card debt I don't know how we got
here
I'll tell you how you got here you dealt
with snakes and then you wondered why
you got bit
so the simplest thing to do is just not
walk into the the old cage Dave yeah I
hope
that you remember this experience the
rest of your life and the next time
someone runs up at you at an airport to
have you sign up
for a free t-shirt for a credit card you
smack them
and walk away giggling I hope that's
what I do you need to recommend you need
to remember this I don't actually Dave's
not scared of assault charges at this
point I'm not really physically but I
mean my God verbally like not a chance
Southwestern not a chance this is the
Ramsey Show